all right everyone welcome to the ddps
seminar uh before we introduce our
invited speaker
let's go over some rules and logistics
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk unless you have questions
if you have questions you are welcome to
unmute and ask otherwise please use
chat room to post your questions so that
we can address them in q a session at
the end
second today's ddps is open
to external audiences
therefore no classified discussion is
allowed so please watch out finally the
talk today will be recorded and uploaded
in our youtube channel that's about it
now let me introduce our speaker today
it is an honor to host
misha
kodak who is a phd student in computer
science at
frank
university advised by nina balkan and
amit
thal walker
his research focuses on foundations and
applications of machine learning in
particular the theoretical and practical
understanding of meta learning and
automation
is a recipient of the facebook phd
fellowship and has spent time
as an intern at microsoft research
new england
and also the lawrence lieberman national
lab and
the princeton plasma physics lab
previously he received a a b in
mathematics and mse in computer science
from princeton university today misha
will talk about tours automatic
architecture design for
emerging machine learning tasks this is
very interesting topic please enjoy and
expect a wonderful talk now without
further due let me pass the button to
misha by asking one random question
question as usual today's random
question is what is your favorite things
to do other than research
uh i like this ski
and
uh i'm learning how to garden very
slowly oh garden okay are you good at
skiing
i'm
decent at skiing i think you're probably
you're better than me all right the
stage is yours
sounds good uh yeah thank you so much
for inviting me uh my name is mitha
kodak and at cmu
and today i hope to give you
uh
some description of some work we've been
doing to design new operations for
machine learning tasks going beyond the
classic tasks that we all know like
vision and text that machine learning is
good towards emerging machine learning
applications
so let's get started
so the past decade in machine learning
as many of you probably know has seen a
lot of advances in many different areas
so it started at the beginning of the
decade with this developments from
university of toronto and google
in visions object detection with
applications for example to self-driving
and text applications so machine
translation was a really big deal
and then later in the decade there was a
lot of progress from especially deep
mind and opening eyes so these large
well-funded startups on things like game
playing protein folding uh even more
advanced text
models
and so this has really been kind of a
large a large amount of progress in a
very very short amount of time spurred
by deep learning models neural networks
and so on in machine learning
so they've achieved these impressive
results in a few specific domains such
as vision so image classification
segmentation and text such as language
prediction translation and some other
tasks where you have a good control over
the environment for example game playing
what the focus of this talk is is really
that we believe that this is really
scratching uh only the tip of the
iceberg for
what machine learning can be applied to
so at the bot at the top you can see we
have
things like transportation so image
detection can be used for autonomous
vehicles uh audio has been had a lot of
progress text has had a lot of progress
but at the bottom there's many other
things that deep learning has maybe
there's been some applications but it is
not an established field where people
are constantly developing new models and
there's lots of funding and lots of
discoveries for these areas such as
you know pde solvers medical
applications
ad tech applications all the way down we
think there's a lot of these
applications that are so far
underexplored that deep learning can be
very easily applied to or should be very
easily applied to but it's not yet
and the reason it's applying deep
learning to these new applications is
trickier is because of the type of
neural networks being used for them are
not actually well tuned for them so we
have these neural networks they're very
effective for
for a vision for text we've developed
very advanced and sophisticated methods
that encode the right biases for these
deep nets on the other hand when we have
data such as experimental data from the
natural sciences simulation data data
based on graphs like social networks or
protein graphs
or biological sequences we don't really
know what neural network we want to use
for them and the goal of this talk is to
push us towards automating uh how to
discover
neural networks for deep for applying
deep learning to these emerging tasks
so the question we're going to ask is
can we automate this tuning of neural
networks and to enable the
straightforward application of deep
learning to many new tasks that you know
people haven't been applying them before
so first let's discuss what a neural
architecture is and maybe
maybe many of you know what this is but
we should go over it anyway just to make
sure we're all on the same page
so a standard picture we have a neural
network is you have some input such as
an image and you pass it through a lot
of matrix multiplications of some kind
and non-linear operations
for example a logistic function sigmoids
that sort of thing you pass it through
several layers that's why it's called
deep and the goal is to
learn
what
numbers to put in these weight matrices
so as to output the right classifier at
the end uh so the the zero one encoding
of the of the word frogs if the input is
a frog and to train uh to train or to
learn the numbers and use weights what
we usually do is we specify some
objective that's large if it's the wrong
answer and smaller fits the right answer
and we apply gradient descent to these
weights and magically nobody knows why
it seems to work well both in terms of
uh training and that we
get global optima and training and also
we do fairly well on test performance so
out of sample performance on samples we
haven't seen and this requires
collecting all of data but it seems to
work pretty well for some tasks
especially computer vision
now this is a very simple neural network
on the left on the right we have a much
more complicated neural network that one
that we've actually been designing so
this is kind of what we started with
with very simple operations what we're
actually designing in a neural network
is this general computational graph
where you have an input it's going to be
passed through
multiple edges on each edge is some
operation so for example a linear
multiplier followed by a non-linearity
it could be an operation and they're
parameterized by a model weight's w and
then the inputs to each x okay each edge
will be past these operations and then
as you
as you go forward through this
computational graph these operations or
these edges can combine their inputs at
each node so for example node four will
combine the inputs of this edge and this
edge through concatenation or addition
or something like that
and you pass it forward to this graph
and eventually you come to your output
which you hope again to be something
that's correct for the input
and so we have been designing
architectures neural networks or the
deep learning community has been
designing these for a very long time so
this human-driven architecture research
as we call it is has generally proceeded
in two different directions
one direction is discovering which
operation we want to use so in the first
slide we had like a linear operation but
of course what really powers computer
vision for example these days are these
convolution operations where instead of
just multiplying the entire input by uh
by a matrix we
apply this convolutional filter which
slides along the input and only
and only allows local
local interactions between
between pixels to
propagate to the immediate next layer
and there there's been a lot of other
designs for what we actually put on the
edges of this graph
most recently transformers have
transformed the field and allowed a lot
of progress in things like protein
folding and so on
the other direction that people proceed
in designing architectures is a network
topology so which of these edges how do
we connect these edges like is edge one
three on or off
should uh should we concatenate or add
and so on uh probably the most famous
of these network topology discoveries in
human driven architecture so which is
the resonant in which we pass an input x
into
into this node
and then there's one edge that applies
some convolutions to that node and
there's another edge that just applies
an identity operation and then they're
summed at the end so basically which
operation to use and
how to connect them is kind of a
topology search question and
discovering operations themselves so
discovering things like convolutions
discovering transformers is more of an
operation search question so these are
the main
directions of progress that humans have
been developing architectures for the
past decade and even earlier you know
convolutional neural networks were
discovered in the 90s
as many of
you have probably seen uh this image of
the improvement of imagenet on imagenet
so this big image classification
benchmark over the past 10 years and
what you we actually want or what i
actually want to show
in in this plot is how important these
discoveries of neural architectures have
been to
uh to drive this progress in machine
learning for example on this benchmark
and not only that but also how
complicated these architectures have
been so on each on the bottom you see
the best architecture from each year up
through 2015 and you can see it keeps
changing and if we zoom in on one of
these architectures this is called
googlenet we can see it's very complex
expert driven architecture design here
so we have a lot of weird choices that
these architecture designers made so for
example we have the structure where we
repeat blocks of the graph as we
propagate the input from the left to the
right
we're going to somehow connect
internally we're going to connect these
blocks somehow so we have edges from
certain nodes but not
from others so for example there's no
node between uh this one and the input
here
uh we have a lot of different operations
we might want to use so in different
places we're going to use a convolution
with a kernel of size three by three in
other areas we're going to use a
convolutional the kernel size five by
five we might use different types of
pooling where we gather
local pixels together uh by taking a max
or an average of them
and of course we also chose to use
convolutions anyway this was also an
architecture decision and the question
becomes say if we're not applying to a
vision task why are we using
convolutions anyway so these are the
sorts of very complicated decisions that
in architecture search we have to
consider
and so
the goal of neural architecture research
as a human architecture
is to automate away this design of
architectures so that non-experts or
so that non-experts can apply it to
their task or to help experts get even
better performance like ink out the last
two accuracy percentage points from
their tasks so if you want to help
practitioners in advanced areas of my ml
where machine learning already does well
such as vision language and so on and
you also want to accelerate progress in
new areas which is our goal today
and i think there has been a lot of
progress in real architecture research
over the past
three years or so
we've discovered that with this repeated
block structure it just always seems to
work so this is often not something we
search we
uh we have lots of architecture so it's
algorithms we've worked on them many
other people have worked on them to
select which topology to use
within each block we have a lot of
algorithms for picking from a small set
of operations which operations to use
within each block
we don't really know why we're using
convolutions for a lot of these other
tests for images they seem to work and
these days if you have a new application
the first thing many people do is
they're going to apply a say a resnet or
vgg or something like that a
convolutional neural network or a cnn to
their problem and both for the best at
least initially
and so the focus but yeah unfortunately
the focus of this existing neural
architecture research has really been on
this first bullet point which is to help
practitioners in areas of a metal that
already work so these architecture merge
search methods glue together existing
primitives so existing operations like
convolutions and those we know already
work well on these heavily study tests
like vision
and the question really becomes like why
are we studying architecture so heavily
uh our architects are searched so
heavily if companies like google and so
on already have many engineers that can
be applied to these tasks you know why
are we why are we working on this field
when we have this whole other area of
research that we might want to work on
to accelerate progress in new areas so
specifically we want to design a search
space in this work that can serve as an
initial automated solution to machine
learning problems on diverse domains
beyond vision text audio and so on
before i go forward are there any
questions about
the motivation of the word
great so let's start first with defining
what the neural architecture search
problem actually is
so remember we have this computational
graph and our goal is to pick an
operation for each edge in this
computational graph to maximize some
objectives such as accuracy latency you
know efficiency memory and so on
uh and so here's our graph and we're
running there's a computer that's
running this architecture research
algorithm and usually what people do if
you have a standard
discrete narrow architecture search
space is we're going to pick which
operation should we use on each of these
edges so are you going to use a
convolution are we going to use an
average pooling or so on and this also
more or less covers
the network connection question because
one of these operations could be the
none operation so we don't pass any
input forward and then there's this edge
is just not connected so if we have a
small set of operations we're going to
redefine it using our search space and
for example this very popular search
space called darts has eight different
operations such as the identity so just
pass the input forward the zero
operation as i was describing past
nothing forward and some convolutions of
various kinds and some pooling and
various kinds these specific operations
aren't that important but this is kind
of
the standard approach neural
architecture search define a very small
set of operations and figure out where
in your neural network to put them
which edge do we put which operation and
hope that this is what we need for our
task
and we know convolutions so all these
operations are sort of convolutional as
we'll see we know that these operations
work well for vision tasks
the question is does this search space
there's a search base of consisting of
just these operations would this work
well for other data domains
so for example other data we might
consider would be sequence modeling so
if you for example want to figure out
what the next word is in
in your sentence that starts with neural
architecture and you might want to have
search here uh this is a sequence
modeling problem that can be modeled as
a multi like multi-dimensional array
input with um
with one sequential dimension and one uh
kind of vocabulary dimension and here it
turns out convolutions work okay but
need to have some special designs to
actually work well like large dilations
and other operations like transformers
work even better
there are other operations this will be
the focus of our empirical evaluation at
least
in this talk is in for example solving
partial differential equations if you uh
if you have say an input at time zero
can you use uh classical solver data to
figure out what the uh what the fluid
state should be at time fifty and here
it turns out convolutions work poorly
although they are closely related to
some state-of-the-art operations such as
the fourier neural operator which i'll
get into later
and then there are many other problems
you might want to use such as prediction
on graphs where regular graph
convolutions bear regular convolutions
doesn't even make sense but there are
graph convolutions that do work well
so we have these many other applications
and many i'm not listing uh
that we don't know that we can just
apply convolutions and expect good
performance and in some cases we
actually get bad performance
on the other hand a lot of these
operations actually
even when we use do use new operations
such as the transformers or this
state-of-the-art pd operation or this
graph convolution we are using fairly
basic topologies so we're using this
residual network topology here or just a
basic like feed forward like the first
neural network i showed you uh is being
used here
and so the question of how we can handle
these domains we think has a pretty
simple solution but uh some other
possible solutions are we can just use
the search space this very small
operation search space anyway uh we
believe this will give you a large gap
in performance it's been seen
empirically and it's not going to
discover truly novel architectures it's
just going to glue together convolutions
pooling layers and so on
you can also add a new operations one by
one as we discover them unfortunately a
lot of discrete nas methods don't scale
well with the number of operations and
we might not know the right operation to
use so we would have to you know employ
human effort and not automation to
discover which operation discover a new
operation for a specific task
and so our argument here is that we need
a more general search space focused on
operations and not on the actual
topology of the network
so we're going to construct a new more
general search space in this talk and
the way we're going to do this is we're
going to start with the darts operations
so remember it's going to contain the
density operation the zero operation
multiple kinds of convolutions and
pooling layers and we're going to
observe that seven of eight of them are
linear so if you give the if you give
them some weights and you give them an
input then the action of the operation
can be expressed as a matrix multiplied
times this input so that's that's the
first thing you can observe and then we
can also observe that since they're all
basically convolutions uh then you can
diagonalize
this matrix a w by
the fourier transform or the dft
so they have this diagonal form where
you apply the fourier
dft to the input
you multiply it by the fourier transform
of your weights padded which uses
underlying just a padding
that doesn't matter too much and then
you
you take the inverse square transform of
the product
and so this this can describe any of
these operations uh
with some modifications
and what this allows us to do is to
replace these discrete fourier
transforms but a more general family of
efficient matrices so it's going to how
we're going to construct a new search
space based on diagonalization rather
than just combining operations you know
using a zero one approach
so before getting actually discussing
what this more general family of
efficient matrices is i'm going to keep
going and uh how we're going to use them
so
right we're going to transform we're
going to replace each of these dfts so
discrete fourier transform matrices by
some other matrix k l and m
and we're going to call
these the architecture parameters of uh
of our search space so they define like
what specifically kl and mr are is going
to define the search space we're going
to use how we're going to encode new
operations in uh in the search base and
we call this search space
xd for expressive diagonalization uh
because you get basically by allowing
your
matrices to vary beyond the discrete
fourier transform you
uh you get a more expressive
diagonalization than if you just use the
convolution approach
so which family of efficient matrices
are we're going to use uh the family we
want is
uh was introduced by our collaborators
in 2020 and they're called kaleidoscope
matrices or k matrices and this is a
really neat uh really neat family of
matrices is basically you take the you
take the
uh fourier the fft
uh fft algorithm structure so as many of
you probably know the fft operates by
applying a successive uh successive
number of small matrices to the input
where each of the entries in these small
matrices is some roots of unity and you
apply this successively and since
they're
since they're nicely structured you can
get a very efficient algorithm to apply
your dft to your input
and so what this paper proposes is to
replace all the entries or all these
roots of unities in the discrete fourier
transform to allow them to take on any
complex number
and the reason this is interesting is
that you can by doing this you can
probably express any efficient matrix of
vector operation so any matrix vector
operation that can be applied to an
input in uh in linear time so what this
is going to include is sparse operations
low rank operations permutations uh
discrete fourier transforms discrete
cosine transforms uh wavelet transforms
um so many different operations that
we're going to see are very useful uh in
architecture search
so going back to our applications we're
going to substitute these k matrices in
for this discrete fourier transform and
use them to define our architecture
space so k l and m which is uh which
kind of encodes what operations we're
using uh where will basically be how
we'll basically define how big our
architecture search space is and the
reason this is nice beyond uh beyond the
properties of the gaming trees they
discussed is that they preserve all this
preserves the efficiency and short
description length of convolutions so
all this because kl and m are still just
uh still have this fast square like
structure uh they still uh maintain the
efficient matrix vector uh
multiplication
uh quality so we're not just using
arbitrary matrices that would be too
complex but on the other hand it allows
us to express many different operations
of interest
and specifically
it allows us to express uh all the
all but one of the operations in the
dart space so that serious space i
discussed before all of them except max
pooling so average filling convolutions
dilations of various kinds they're all
included in the search space which i'm
representing by this blue blob
uh it also is going to include all
convolutions in the popular uh python uh
neural networks package called pytorch
it which has that many dilated
convolutions it has transpose
convolutions and so on it can express
all of those convolutions so you can
search over like when searching this
operation search base it can search over
all these convolutions
a very neat result is that we can
actually express graph convolutions for
fixed graphs and the reason we can do
this is because graph convolutions
basically depend on multiplying the
input by the adjacency matrix of the
graph roughly speaking and since the
adjacency matrix matrix is sparse it can
be represented by k matrices and so it
is contained in our search space once
you work out the math
and finally yes
what about
the fully connected layers and uh
activations
uh so fully connected layers uh is kind
of a tricky question some people might
say that fully connected layers are
equivalent to a convolution with uh
with a filter size one but that's
not necessarily the case uh the issue
with fully connected layers is that
they're a bit too expressive if you
apply them to the full image so
we can't necessarily express those
unless you allow your parameter space to
be really large
um your other question was about uh
activations um activations are
non-linear operation and so we can't
actually express them uh one of the one
of the key things we identified with uh
with all these darts operations is that
seven out of eight of them were linear
so they had this form where once you
gave them parameters uh they could
express a w they could be expressed as a
linear matrix multiplied times x for
some a right
but non-linear non-linear activation
functions won't have that property so
that's why we can't for example have max
pooling and also operation and also
activations
um but we can still search over them
using some other algorithm it's just it
won't be covered by this experience
okay
thanks for the question
right and so the last thing i think
that's uh i think very neat also is that
it expresses the fourier neural operator
i'll get into exactly how it expresses
that later
and this is the state of the r at least
before us for these neural pd solvers
that people have been developing
at least on the benchmarks that they
guessed
okay so now that we have this search
space of xd operations
we're going to briefly discuss how we
can actually use them uh to do this
we're going to
we're going to mod modify the standard
pipeline for how people might use other
deep neural networks in practice
so the standard pipeline is you obtain
your data
you choose some convolutional network
topologies such as linnet resnet vgg
there's many networks that people have
come up with
and then you're going to apply your this
neural network to uh and by training
model ways for it by using stochastic
gradient descent or some other
gradient-based optimization algorithm
such as atom
on some loss function depending on how
well this network fixed your data fits
your data and then you're what you're
going to do is it's not going to work
the first time
so you're going to evaluate how well it
did on some uh some validation data say
and tune as needed so tune your
optimizer maybe choose a different
topology so on
the way we're going to apply xd
operations is
quite simple once we just basically a
simple insertion into uh into the
standard pipeline what we're going to do
is replace all convolutions in this
convolutional mirror network by an xd
operation initialize as convolutions
we're going to call this also warm
started as convolutions and the re the
way we specifically do this as uh if you
remember the k matrices that we use to
parameterize our architecture search
space we're going to initialize them as
the dfts or inverse dfts as needed
to kind of make sure that the network
starts as a convolution because it seems
convolutions are a good starting point
at least and then we're going to allow
them to vary uh these architecture
parameters to vary uh together with the
model weights by also training them
using some algorithm such as to cast the
gradient descent or atom and again we
will tune all this also is needed but
it's just basically an extra a little
amount of tuning for the architecture
optimizing
so before i get into some empirical
results that we have are there any more
questions on
the setup uh and on the design of our
architecture systems
sorry on the previous slide i'm not
clear are you doing bi-level
optimization as in friendship
architectures or is
it's a great question
so in
in this work we don't do bi-level
optimization in this work we're actually
just going to do simultaneous training
of uh of the model weights and the
architecture parameters
this does indeed go against some or
maybe most architecture search
algorithms we'll do this by level
optimization step uh and there's no real
reason why you can't apply to our in our
case but we found that uh
simultaneous optimization so single
level works
well enough and is simpler
so we used single level in this case
that's a great question
okay thank you
so i have one one question i think i'm
following all this but just to make sure
there are no
integer
variables everything's continuous
yes this is an excellent question uh
indeed there is no integer variables uh
or no like binary variables and so on
and this indeed is kind of a difference
from standard architecture search
algorithms or search spaces right where
it's really a question of do i use a
three by three convolution or a five by
five convolution or average pooling
these are all discrete questions that
you can encode as indeed an integer or
kind of like a binary string
um and so yeah there there is no
discrete there's no discreteness here so
we train these architecture parameters
and
after training we don't do anything with
them we don't have to discretize or
anything we can just apply gradient
descent and be happy
yeah that that's awesome
thank you great questions
okay great so i'll keep going then uh to
discuss some applications which we're
pretty excited about
um i'm going to really focus on the
applications that i think are very
relevant to livermore and i think are
the most exciting uh kind of discoveries
in our work um but before going into
that we do have a variety of different
tasks we evaluated on so remember our
goal was to see how well neural networks
do on a diverse set of tasks so kind of
to present this work we need to evaluate
on a diverse set of tasks so for example
as a baseline we started by seeing you
know
regular cnns do well on regular image
classification uh the question is
uh or what we try is permuted image
classification where we apply a
permutation to the rows and columns of
an image so for example this image of a
horse if you apply some permutation to
it you'll get
what looks like nonsense nonsense on the
right but in principle if you unpermute
this then you should be able to do just
as well with a cnn as long as you have a
permutation in front of it right so if
we apply it to that we do much better
than a cnn
and part partially the reason is because
permutations followed by convolutions
are also an operation in our search
space which is great unfortunately we
don't do quite as well as exactly on
permeating and then applying a cnn but
that's of course i think quite a
difficult problem
and then we go on to less toys tasks so
for example predicting uh distance
prediction and protein folding which is
a two-dimensional problem where you
extract some features from uh your
protein strings and you try to predict
uh the
correct distances between them uh and
this is part of the kind of protein
folding pipeline that's been popularized
by things like alpha fold from deepmind
that you may have heard they use the
transformer model here it's much more
advanced but we're just doing a baby
evaluation use then comparing to the
cnns and we also perform cnn's at least
here
and also we look at next note prediction
in sheet music so kind of an alternative
to language modeling you can predict
notes in like what is the next note in
uh corral or a fugue um
and here we also outperform uh regular
convolutional neural networks with even
if the neural networks have this custom
designed dilation pattern
but the focus i think of this talk will
be on neural pde solving
so that i'll get into that now
so neural pd solvers
maybe many of you have seen uh seen some
of this work but the setup is basically
that you
you want to sample problems a partial
differential equation solving problems
from some distribution over the initial
conditions of say a fluid state
and for each problem we're going to
generate a quote-unquote ground trade
solution this might have error as solver
as classical solvers do
but we're going to generate this what
we'll call a round-trip solution using
some standard solver such as crank
nicholson or we can go more advanced but
this is what the machine learning
community has used
and we're going to train a neural
network to learn a function from these
initial conditions to a later state so
at time equals zero we have this uh
initial condition of the fluid state
we'll run crank nicholson to get
the solution at time equals 50 and this
is going to be our training data our
goal is to train a neural network that
predicts from some distribution over
initial conditions like this what the
final condition what the final state of
the fluid will be at time
and 50.
targeted application here is to directly
use this so i think uh if you have a
kind of a repeated repeated need to
solve partial differential equations
start starting from some distribution
over similar uh similar initial states
and similar boundary conditions and so
on
then this might be useful because this
uh this will only be one forward pass
through a neural network rather than
running an iterative solver for many
time steps
another big application this is inverse
problems so here if you have a final
state and you have some distribution
that you want to solve over initial
states can you
use can you learn
uh can you learn solutions such that you
can basically sample from your initial
distribution and basically speed up your
markov chain monte carlo algorithm for
your inverse problem uh to figure out
the initial state faster
and then of course there is the idea of
transferring to new problem domains say
you have a
say you can train a very
like a very coarse-grained solver
neural network solver can you use that
to improve uh classical solver and so on
and so the operations that people have
been using for
training these neural pd solvers uh
really started with the standard
approach of can we apply convolution to
this problem so this is going to be the
baseline we're going to use people apply
a cnn to these inputs they're nice 2d 1d
3d inputs so we can apply our standard
convolutions to them
unfortunately convolutions don't work
quite well here at least in the settings
we've looked at
and many other people have looked at the
performance decreases as the resolution
increases and so the issue is as you
want as you want to increase the
resolution of
the grid you're evaluating on the
performance is going to get worse and in
general the performance is also just not
good the relative error is high as
wilson
now this year at uh at a machine
learning conferences the conference
there was uh introduced a dysphoria
neural operator or fno uh from a group
at caltech and it resulted in much
stronger performance that was three
orders of magnitude faster than
traditional solvers so this was not a
improvement over convolutions but uh the
forward pass through this network based
on this flair neural operator was much
faster than running a traditional solver
on the same problem and you got
consistent performance also across
resolutions which it was a big plus
and now what we're going to do is
compare xd operations to these two
uh older operations
so the great thing about xc operations
and we didn't design it this way but
this uh we've discovered that xdf
reasons contain a lot of new a lot of
existing things uh they contain both
convolutions and fnos we'll see epinos
how they contain epinopes in a bit
they are slower but we still believe
they're fast enough to be useful so
they're basically maybe two and a half
two to two and a half orders of magnetic
faster than traditional solvers rather
than three orders of magnitude and we'll
discuss some ways that we're looking at
to improve their efficiency
so first we'll look at what the square
neural operator is
and basically what it is is you take
your convolution and you get rid of this
fourier transform that you apply to your
filter weights so it's basically the
identity operation
and then you then you basically apply it
in the same way you might apply a
convolution
and the great thing about this uh in our
case at least is that this of course is
also an xd operation right because we
used to have a fourier transform here uh
to initialize our kl and m uh now we
know that an identity operation is a
very efficient operation it uh is
contained in the set of k matrices we're
using to encode these so it is of course
also an xd operation
and these fourier neural operators on
say an inverse problem requiring uh
three thousand uh thirty thousand solves
uh they can determine the initial
vorticity of a neighbor stroke system uh
in two and a half minutes at least as
advertised although this kind of hides
the twelve hours it takes to generate
the training data using cranktanklesson
and to train the network um
but it's still faster than your standard
solver which takes 18 hours now this is
fmo this is not us
this is kind of the motivation of this
work and kind of the baselines that
we're going to be comparing against
are there any questions so far
okay so the experiments we're going to
consider taken directly from
from previous work
is the burgers equations on the domain
from zero to one with random initial
conditions a darcy flow on a 2d domain
also with random initial conditions and
two dna stokes on the zero to one domain
or 2d domain but also with the time
domain and with some random initial
verticity
and the discretization is going to just
be a square grid in time and we're going
to measure performance and as the
average of squared losses of our grid
vertices uh normalized to the so
basically the relative error
and we're going to borrow all backbone
networks and settings from this previous
fno paper where possible to ensure fair
comparison
okay so on the
1d and 2d problems without the time
component so the kind of simpler
problems to study this is how a cnn does
so on the x-axis you have the resolution
so starting at around 100 cells and
going up to about 10 10 000 cells in the
1d case and from around 100 to 400 cells
in the 2d case you can see that as you
as you increase the resolution the
performance of the cnn backbone gets
worse uh in terms of l2 relative error
so it starts off not great and it gets
worse as you increase the resolution
on the other hand this uh
this xd approach so we basically uh
insert xd into so initialize with the
same network the same convolutional
neural network
but allow both the model weights and
the dfts so the k matrices initializes
dfts to vary and if we train them
together then it turns out that we can
get good and consistent performance
across resolutions so you'll see that we
have much better performance and
it's much flatter especially in the 2d
case on darcy flow but also in berger's
equation basically get
good performance across all resolutions
using this approach
and it turns out it's even better than
uh this custom design for a neural
operator approach uh which does do much
better than cnn but remember is custom
design we all we had uh to train our
approach was you know our xd approach
and knowledge of convolutions whereas f
and l was custom design so even though
we knew that con that
uh that fnl is contained in the xd space
we didn't use it we didn't use that fact
to actually get this good result and it
turns out that if you initialize xd with
fnos it actually does slightly worse
than initializing them with convolutions
which is a somewhat surprising result to
us considering how much better fnos do
here
and then our second or last set of
evaluations for the pde problem we also
looked at navier stokes and here we got
a very similar story over here we're
tracking across viscosities rather than
resolutions again in terms of uh l2
relative error on the y-axis and you'll
see that we again do much better than uh
cnns using xd operations despite
starting or initializing our
architecture search with a convolution
and it again does slightly better than
the fno in this study
so to recap uh the reason we might want
to use uh our xd operations uh is or the
reason why we think this is an exciting
line of work in general for many
applications and not just pd solvers is
that you can transform any convolutional
neural network background so a resonant
vgg and so on into a search space over
operations and you can find something
better than convolutions for any problem
you might think of
and so in this work i've really focused
only on the partial differential
equations operation but we've looked at
a lot of a lot of different
applications where this has actually
worked well so for example we've uh we
found it worked well on permuted image
classification or image classification
where instead of permuting we just
flatten the image and pretend it's a 2d
or a 1d problem so these are kind of toy
problems but our approach works well
here as we discussed it works quite well
on neural pd solving
it works well on this module for
distance prediction for protein folding
which is an emerging application that
people are applying many models to
there's a lot of focus on this but i
think the fact that it works that just
starting from cnn and our approach
already improves upon that is a positive
sign
and it works we've also seen improvement
both on kind of classical sequence
modeling tests so language modeling text
prediction predicting the next word we
saw some improvement over convolutions
there but also in less study tasks like
music modeling or
some also results on financial time
series
of course uh not everything can work
well on everything so uh to be
completely transparent we have also
not done a lot better than the baseline
on kind of your more standard tasks like
image classification so convolutions
seem to already work great for image
classification and we
so far haven't seen
our operations improve upon image
classification yet
and similarly for audio classification
it seems that convolutions do quite well
and we don't see much improvement using
these xd operations
i think uh
broadly speaking i think these results
where we do much better on some
applications and not others uh is
indicative of the fact that you know
these existing applications are really
located in this
tip of the iceberg setting where we
we've studied them for a long time and
we're not going to possibly see much
improvement using uh or see very strong
improvement using something like a more
general search space for operation on
the other hand i think a lot of these
applications do come in the more
emerging applications in machine
learning or off machine learning and we
hope to see
a lot more a lot more progress using
something like this or work that builds
on it in the future
now i'd also like to get into what xd is
not uh and it's not a replacement for
classical topology search neural
architecture search algorithms so for
example uh the dart space uh i think
deep hyper from argonne um and many
other application approaches that kind
of
decide which operations to use uh where
and so on decide connectivity in the
neural network and so on uh what we
believe is that these remain important
and that xd is solving a somewhat
different problem of discovering new
operations and not necessarily
connecting existing ones
and we haven't done this yet but i think
the right approach here is to use them
in conjunction
with these
classical approaches general
architecture search where we for example
we might find a good convolutional
neural network first and then apply xd
operations
and the reason we think this is a good
idea is because
so far at least in our evaluations of
things like darts and uh not d piper but
things like auto deep lab
on for example pds shows that they alone
using them alone is not sufficient to
get good performance so for example is
auto deep lab which is a classic
neural architecture search approach
actually does get consistent performance
across resolutions but consistently bad
performance
compared to say the fno or the xd
so we believe using them in tandem might
be a fruitful direction
it's also not a direct way to improve
efficiency of your network uh applying
xd to a cnn so there is a large cost to
replacing your
uh your for your uh your dfts by uh by
xd operations or by k matrices uh it is
uh five times slower to train for
example on the pde test
on the protein task it's two times
slower and similarly for inference it's
currently slower and these are things we
have to work on in order to get this uh
to actually perform well and be useful
on some of these tasks especially if a
computation is critical for usefulness
such as in the pde task
and there are also large memory costs
currently associated with this so yeah
this is definitely uh kind of ongoing
work that we're working on
and specifically to get into this uh the
inefficiency in xd operations is
actually pretty hard to nail down uh but
there's dependence on new software for k
matrices you know we're competing with
this paper uh with ffts which is a
classic algorithm with lots of work over
many years decades
and we're competing we're
replacing this
by
by something that was introduced a
couple years ago maybe one year ago
and we're basically still working on how
to actually make this fast
and there's other reasons we can't take
advantage of say the permission symmetry
of dft um
and the kernel filters we have to pad
them to the input size before
multiplying them and this of course all
adds to
the complexity but ongoing efforts is to
actually develop this better software or
to develop alternative structured
matrices that are more gpu friendly so
all this is trained on gpus how can we
make structured matrices that are as
expressive or similarly expressive to
these k matrices but actually make them
run efficiently
and also developing approximations or
truncations that can speed things up
while not losing too much in accuracy
we're also working on benchmarking so as
we proceeded with this problem it turned
out that evaluating neural architecture
search on many of these tests was more
non-trivial than we expected
it's difficult to define what a diverse
task is how many do you need to evaluate
on how do you actually compare different
methods if you have a lot of tasks to
evaluate on and how do you consider
computational tradeoffs uh so this is
something we're working on with this
benchmark for neural architecture search
called mass bench 360 which can be found
at this website
uh currently you have 10 tasks which are
understudied but feasible to evaluate on
an academic budget they include many
different tasks
from the protein so the pd solving tasks
we've discussed the protein folding
tasks from genomics audio and so on
and we also have evaluated different
methods at different budget constraints
on these tasks and have some interesting
results
and finally uh
there's uh we're also working on new
search spaces so so far we've developed
a search space that contains a lot of
interesting operations as i've discussed
it contains graph convolutions and
agencies fno operations many different
kind of standard convolutions or
transpose convolutions uh and of course
an infinite number of operations because
it is a continuous space on the other
hand it doesn't contain everything
as was mentioned it doesn't contain
things like max pooling or
non-linearities it doesn't contain
self-attention uh so this is a plot of
what like this transformer architecture
self-attention architecture actually is
and so
so of course it's not going to contain
everything we might want because there
are many different nonlinear operations
that we might care about and but the
goal i think is to see if similar ideas
to xd can be applied to define
new search spaces that are efficient to
search over but contain maybe some of
these operations and of course many more
so different types of convolutions say
approximations to self-attention which
is a very important task since
self-attention is quadratic can we
define uh can we similarly find kind of
an elegant definition such as ours
to encode these
operations in a way that makes them
searchable uh and also usable for uh for
new applications
and so that largely con concludes my
talk uh i hope you uh i hope i've
convinced you of the importance of using
of studying diverse applications
using neural architecture search and i
hope you can also try out our method
which is available as software on github
i'd like to thank my collaborators of
course nick roberts who co-led the work
with me uh tree dial liam lee chris ray
and amy talker
and you can also see our paper which
will appear at the nerves conference and
machine learning uh this december uh it
is an archive and of course please feel
free to email me
with any questions
thank you thank you so much yeah thank
you thank you misha for the wonderful
talk it was wonderful uh let's have a q
and a sessions
um you can either post your questions to
the chat room or you can unmute yourself
and
directly ask questions let me start with
my question then while you guys are
preparing your questions
so the challenge of the pd is over is
that as
the problem can get
pretty complex and becomes large
very easily and therefore the simulation
data can be large and
you know the corresponding image can be
very large and
therefore the you know this
arc the neural net architecture it has
to include a lot of
parameters and noise and edges etc so
um i guess the xd is slower actually
than the the cnn
in terms of training so i guess that has
to be
addressed further in order to be
applied to a lot truly large-scale
problem i guess
if you can connect on that
yes so that that is definitely true in
order to apply
in order to apply this to truly large
scale pde problems you will need to you
will need to address this problem uh
there is i think some hope and that uh
our collaborators are working on i think
uh more uh like better uh structured
matrices than the k matrices that might
be faster more cpu friendly uh there's
also work on
uh on
truncating uh the things we need to do
or they're kind of truncating the
uh the outputs of or the input to these
k matrices in order to make the input
smaller while not actually losing so
much air it's a bit difficult to get
into but basically there's a lot of
padding involved that and you end up
with a lot of zeros and places um in the
internals once you try to actually
multiply all these things and kind of
getting rid of these zeros would
hopefully get
uh hopefully get you better results
um i think they're also hope in the
sense that for example fno
is actually a very efficient operation
not r not xd but fno is actually quite
efficient uh it is more efficient i
think than cnns at least in the
applications we've tried
um
and there's hope i think in uh in sort
of using uh using similar structures to
what they're doing so for example uh
restricting ourselves to a search space
that contains fnos but does not contain
convolutions there are ways to do that
that i think might be faster than
forcing ourselves to contain
convolutions uh so i think there there
are definitely directions for making
this faster for that application
specifically
and yep that those directions will
hopefully be useful to other
applications that also require speed
yep um cannot wait until until that's
actually come true my next question is a
some sort of clarification um question
xd you said cannot apply
to the nonlinear operators such as the
activate some nonlinear activation
functions
but that doesn't mean that you cannot
use activation nonlinear activation
function in your neural net it's it's
just you are not searching for those um
you know activation function
yeah that's exactly true yes um yeah
it's just you substitute in like a
convolution is itself not a nonlinear
operation you substitute it for the
convolution uh but then you maintain the
non-linearity after it um that's network
so yes all our networks doesn't contain
revolutions yes
great great okay is there any other
question from audiences
you can
uh okay kevin asked
how much more expensive is it on memory
usage
i guess it's talking about actually
yes
so memory is also it can also be
challenging um it can be
up to
2x more expensive 5x more expensive on
memory as well um
i think it basically aligns with uh with
the computational expense
and this is something also that we're
working on uh
yeah
i think specifically the the idea of
truncation uh which is something that
fno uses to make themselves make it more
efficient is something that will
hopefully also make this more efficient
and basically reduce the ma the like
large kind of entries of zeros were
passing around
right sounds good thank you um the next
question is from charles uh
if it's he asked if it's too expensive
to apply xd on his full data will it be
worthwhile to apply xt on
part of his data let's say
he could only
run xd on
hundredth or thousandth of uh useful
data
a partial application
yeah so certainly there's a question of
whether you can uh whether you can
develop trade-offs between having more
samples and having uh having a more
expensive network right so for example
the fno approach since it's more
efficient you might be able to run it on
more data
more quickly
and get better results on the other hand
to train xd uh it takes a lot longer and
so you might not be able to train on as
much data but it is a bit better so you
can develop kind of like a trade-off
curve there of at some point maybe i
need if i have enough data you know i've
run
my classical solver for long enough
uh then
uh then you should maybe use fno uh or
if you don't have a lot of data um then
you can use xd uh and that will be
better it really it does depend on your
problem and maybe there is a trade-off
that can be found that is advertises
for our case
okay great um
all right um i have one more questions
you said
well
i'm just curious um
you suggested to combine the you know
um
you know coupled search type of nis and
your xd types of nih um they can be
combined um maybe
purples can be um you know optimized
first and then applied xd after that
how about like you know optimizing both
simultaneously you know both searches
the base
do you think that is possible
uh it's a bit
it's going to be a bit trickier i think
to do that simultaneously
depending on exactly how you want to do
it
but it might be tricky because the dart
search space and many other kind of
classical topology search spaces are
discrete
and so if you optimize them
simultaneously you're going to have to
round after your training procedure and
that might
ruin kind of any benefit you're getting
from xd
uh because you've kind of changed your
network structure dramatically once
you've rounded
got it okay yeah so it's like you're
solving like
discrete continuous optimization
simultaneously
yes yeah and so that's difficulty there
okay
sounds good
all right
is there any other questions from
audience
you cannot mute yourself and ask
questions directly
well if not uh let's thank our speaker
today for the wonderful talk michelle
from carnegie mellon um i think we all
have learned a lot and
and we all agree that
xt or nas in general is very useful um
so thank you so much misha what a
wonderful talk and i hope that um the
future collaborations will uh will will
happen uh you know after this uh the
ddps seminar so thank you let's thank
misha
thank you so much for having me this is
very great questions great great all
right let's uh conclude um the the
seminar today thank you so much everyone
to joining us and i think we will have
another gdpr seminar next week
if not then two weeks from today until
then stay healthy everyone okay bye
everyone